welcome to this video this is Pat
Bateman playing I hope he doesn't do
anything evil to me that name is kind of
spelling trouble and at the moment you
stop doing anything not even moving ok
come on if he goes for the way he
doesn't ok let's play solid ya know two
nights defense and crazy complications
ok let's playing this the water main
line of the Italian game jack it's not
very dangerous but still decent
alternative yeah 94 is an interesting
move that gives them a little bit choice
than I am actually can't win ce o--'s
wats the name Vince us Marcus retired
since 2005 yeah foreign retired person
you're playing check playing blitz chess
quite a bit here okay so i can go king
of 84 simple play on yeah let's do that
let's keep it simple check this end game
check
check the other option is a bit more
interesting and maybe I should have done
that the instead of ninety two of them
this nap what is the other line set up
king of aid I mean d5 is a bit more
interesting but ok I mean it's not that
I don't have a problem there but it's
difficult to win the game and I
definitely want to try that ok so he's
giving me a too but he has 94 that's
definitely an interesting or that's
definitely in a valid argument so maybe
just here Jack night before I have to
check gras Arvind nah no not at all I
have the better pawn structure it's
still it's so very dry that's true but
I'm not going to take a draw him so
let's just cover the sound drink and go
from there it is very Jewish but still I
can play on him check check check ok but
he's just going into the endgame him
hmm interesting yeah he has p
potentially has a pass on but i have the
i have from this isolated pawn to play
against interesting
huh it's very likely to draw
the thing that what what really what I
see what is what is he doing here if I
go g6 f5 I take h5 g6 takes takes King 6
i'm in the square g 6 f five checks age
6 I don't get it I don't get that sorry
maybe I'm overlooking some breakthrough
but I thought you had to go f5
I don't care don't understand that I
really don't what is this what is he
doing here I'm totally in the square i
mean just winning here easily just
miscounted or something I don't know it
was just a total draw the same game yeah
he had made some kind of miss count and
do i do this silly things all the time
in the end came mostly when I have no
time on the clock but he had he had
quite a bit of time white resins chair
let's have a look at that mean okay if
he goes f5 he's totally okay the
computer is actually having some doubts
about my position there I don't get that
one why is this a problem I don't get it
okay now the computer is changing
evaluations I couldn't really think I'm
worst I thought I just go see five here
and I should be okay if I go age six he
has g5 this is an interesting
interesting thing takes f6 ever take he
promotes maybe I have this move this is
a funny move like this and then I'm
probably winning because I have those
points under control and i have this
pawn and the potential see porn passer
those are more dangerous than the
connected ones yeah computer is giving
me a complete win there so this means
that probably g5 is not possible then
aged 6 is an interesting move because
that it totally it hinders his majority
it can maybe do this for g5
sting wow this is an interesting way to
play takes and c5 get it getting a quick
passage g5 I have to check see form
Kings there and what about this computer
says draw 000 probably some kind of
Perpetual check hmm yeah it was a very
tense key opponent came here interesting
really this is this is a weird idea when
he probably just just miscalculated the
breakthroughs I would have wouldn't have
played h-60 I would have played c5 I
think and this losses aha I don't
understand why exactly g5 is winning
okay
Wow why am I losing this and then King
b3 is given by the combats winning yeah
it's against the zooks one says oops wow
wow that's that's great I have no move I
cannot move any of these pawns and then
then g6 is winning for f6 and promotion
I have no no King moves now I'd he plays
f6 necks and wins so I cannot move any
porn there if i take he goes f6 and
promotes if i go check he goes I don't
know it's not madam man i guess like
here and what am i doing now I'm running
out of moves now I can do this but he
just stops me and now I'm in zouk swung
again and my King has to move and then
these pawns promote very tricky endgame
yeah so I probably would have lost it
because I didn't see that King is
success is a possibility damn so h6
would have been would have been the way
to go with them interesting what is best
then can your phone right and then then
this a 3 c 5 idea i can try c5
immediately maybe txtx g5g asscheeks if
i do this f6 check this now that that's
a funny mistake by the way here yeah
this is funny tale here and we have this
funny little motif a giant I'm winning
the Queen down so he has to play King up
and now my pawns I mean I can do this
which is suppose to something that we've
seen earlier I can also do this h-60 3
takes takes age 72 Queens Queens
and and draw again yeah so it should
have been a draw but it would have been
very tricky I wonder if I could have
played differently somehow c5 yeah those
those end games are notoriously
difficult to play g6 and now f5 is
probably he's killing himself with that
move yes that loses it wasn't necessary
the comp just gives age 6 as a draw yeah
I I wasn't sure the issue is he still
has this f5 ideas if I go here yeah he
takes takes and goes at five Teague's g6
and I'm and I'm losing so I have to
probably play king in 6 cm to stop the
tactical idea and now he probably can go
kingi form hmm that might be a zoosk one
here computer says this wins interesting
so this is this is the move according to
the engine yeah the engine of course and
in this kind of position if you let if
you give it a little bit of time just a
couple of seconds it will calculate this
to the end so the computer is perfect
perfect here of course even though i
don't have in this pre-installed engine
I don't have any table bases but it just
calculates deep enough this is a draw
well let's level look now takes txsu 5
that looks very normal can you form see
for this should loser but before as
possible
and this is a draw funny enough if i go
here again i'm getting killed so i have
to play i can go to e7 actually ok what
if i do this is this is this also draw
this is a funny mistake because he's in
there in the box here and stops my porn
I have to play this and then March the H
pawn h5 be fine yeah it's a drop by
perpetual check wow that was an
interesting endgame very interesting
King and so on a shame yeah the rook
endgame is it is draw a show you Jewish
but ok it's yes you see there are
sometimes interesting points afterwards
I could have easily lost the game as
well ok thanks for watching